Pascal a procedural highlevel
programming language famous for teaching
a generation of kids from the 70s and
80s how to code it was created by
Nicholas worth in the late 1960s and
named after French mathematician blae
Pascal it was originally based on the
alol 60 language but expanded its data
structuring abilities allowing
developers to build Dynamic recursive
data structures like trees and graphs it
got its big break when it became the
language of choice on the Apple 2 then
Lisa and the Macintosh and eventually
became the default highlevel language on
nearly every PC over the years it
evolved into a variety of other dialects
most famously turbo Pascal brought to
you by CP Creator Anders hilburg it was
one of the first languages with its own
full screen IDE and in 1983 you could
buy a copy at Circuit City for only
$49.99 which believe it or not was a
great deal it was used extensively in
education to teach people how to code
but also used to build serious desktop
applications and games such as crisis
Mountain gravity Wars and IBM's alleycat
in modern times its popularity has
declined but Pascal dial like Deli are
still in use today and you might find
its syntax surprisingly familiar to get
started install a compiler like the free
Pascal compiler then create a file
ending in. pasas as an alternative you
might use a dedicated IDE like Lazarus
first we use the program keyword to
define the main entry point for the app
then we add the begin and end keyword
with a period which will execute the
actual code in the program this is like
the main function in many other
languages from here we can use the
built-in right line function to say
hello world Pascal is a procedural
language which means instructions are
executed in a linear sequence one after
the other const is used to Define
immutable global data while VAR is used
to define values that might change
throughout the execution of the program
variables are strongly typed using a
syntax that looks almost identical to
typescript now our main program can be
organized into subprograms of which
there are functions and procedures
notice how they end with a semicolon and
not a period indicating a subprogram at
first glance they look identical but the
difference is that a function returns a
value while a procedure is only used to
execute code or create side effects like
this isod function takes an integer as
an argument then returns a Boolean value
we use some conditional logic to
determine that then assign the result to
the function name itself which tells
Pascal to return that value from the
function now we can call the function
from the main program and get a value
back Pascal is also very good at complex
data structuring like we might create a
custom type for a record which is a key
value pair or a dictionary in other
languages from there we can assign that
type to a variable then create records
and access their fields with notation
and now that all the code is in place we
can build the executable with the
compiler this has been Pascal in 100
seconds thanks for watching and I will
see you in the next
one